foreign  [Music]  don't know when  but I know we'll meet again some sunny  day hello  [Music]  a lot of people ask what will jackass be  like once we're older well it'll get  more mature  the faster you pedal your bike the  faster the other guy's hand goes back  you said it wasn't gonna Feel Like  Anything percussions aren't great but as  long as you have them before you're 50  it's cool and Knoxville's 49.  so we're good  [Music]  Can You Feel My Heart  wow  today we're going to do a little  Furniture shopping  I've been watching jackass since I was  12 years old  and guess what we're here  [Applause]  we have winners and we have Stevo there  ain't a bunch of NASA scientists right  here  what did you guys do to Eric  I also prepare prepare to fail  you still got those million dollar teeth  that's for sure  laughs  she didn't set myself up for failure on  this one Aaron please relax I'm trapped  and you're putting honey on me and  salmon  oh my God  [Music]  oh my gosh  thank you  okay